hi and welcome from the chess club this
class center of st. Louis my name is
Ryan and I'm Katherine an underrated
player somehow works here this is our
brand new youtube series blunders with
Catherine and Ryan we make mistakes so
you don't have to Catherine remind our
viewers what's a blunder well I'm sure
you watch the last video but a blunder
in chess is when you make a very bad
move often caused by not paying
attention to what your opponent is doing
moving too quickly or just not seeing
what piece is under attack I bet we'll
see a lot of those today Catherine did
you know in chess annotation blunders
are typically marked with double
question marks after the move all right
Catherine let's look at one of my games
where I make a pretty bad blunder he's
sure Dan Ryan in this game I'm playing
black lights last move was Queen f4
threatened to bring the Queen closer to
the Kings side to checkmate me I played
c5 revealing an attack on the rook on h1
white overreact to my threat and play
rook h2 but what should white really
have done here to punish me for my
mistake do you think you see it the
answer is Queen h6 and once he moves
there I cannot stop the devastating
attack on my King side that's a
checkmate Catherine let's take a look at
one of your games now Yeah right it's
okay that you make mistakes because I
make them too so over the last couple of
moves I manch lose a few pawns and now
the triumphant Black Knight has my rook
and my queen 4ch if you were playing
white viewers what move would you play
Ryan you can think about this too hmm do
you guys think you have it
here I should take that pesky night out
of the game with the bishop but what
happened instead oh right instead I
played rook to d1 setting myself up for
absolute disaster I really lucked out
whoever because black Chuck my ruck
instead of my queen show the viewers why
that's a disaster what should black have
done here Oh Ryan I'm glad you asked
black should have taken my queen putting
me in check however isn't it really
wonderful but our opponents make
mistakes too it certainly is Katherine
all right well thanks for watching the
second installment of blunders with
Catherine and Ryan you've seen the worst
of us now we want to see the worst of
you please send your blenders the email
below for a call out of the show and a
mystery prize is that it for today Ryan
that's it for today Catherine boy losing
your queen was a royal blunder
[Applause]